Film Courage: What is the producer's rep?
Circus Road Films’ Founder Glen
Reynolds: It's like a sales agent,
it's another name for a sales agent so
in the it usually connotes being a domestic sales
agent as opposed to an international sales agent
it's a little different in that as a producer
rep you are selling films to U.S distributors
and in doing so there's you don't really have
to take over the film from the filmmaker you
can make the deal you can negotiate on
their behalf and then they can deliver
the film to the distributor and distributor can
pay them directly it's a fairly easy transaction
whereas on the international front International
sales agents really have to take over that process
so International sales agents are more like
distributors in that you deliver them the film
and then they go to markets around the world
sell these Distributors and then in turn
deliver the film to those Distributors collect
that money and then account to a a producer
so in my case I don't do that I specialize in
U.S Distributors and as most producer apps do
and I'm just like a consultant
sales agent for that purpose
between a producer's rep and so a producer
rep is really trying to get the film maker the
best deal possible in the United States
with a with a traditional distributor
Distributors are are taking on the film played
in theaters put it on video and demand making
Blu-rays selling the rights to Netflix or HBO
and putting on an advertising video on demand
later like Tubi or Pluto so they're usually most
Distributors are handling all rights that way
as a producer rep I'm mean the filmmaker usually
about the time they finish the film or about to
get into film festival or just got into a film
festival and I'm going to help them get into
the world of distribution and show the film
to the Distributors to see who would be the
best possible partner for taking the film out
why would a filmmaker hire a producer rep well
especially if you're a first time filmmaker
most schools don't teach film distribution
and so there's just a huge learning Gap in
terms of like what distribution is and what
they do and usually I consider my part of my job
as education in terms of teaching my clients what
Distributors do and which Distributors do it
better than who and part of my job is to know
who's doing it legitimately and who's not doing
it legitimately and who takes an appropriate
distribution fee for putting the film out into
the world who's kind of trying to rip them off
and so it's to protect them as well so
there's there's really just the knowledge of
distribution that's one reason another is just
protection and in addition some salesmanship
I'm trying to get the best possible deal
out there and some filmmakers a filmmaker
in theory could wear all those hats if they got
to learn the distribution landscape and learn
who all the Distributors are and learned how
to negotiate these contracts and had a sales
hat in addition to a creative hat there are
those types right that that could do it all
I'm here for the ones that don't and producer reps
in general are there for the people who can't that
need some help in that in that area have you ever
experienced that where someone says I went to AFM
I go on IMDb Pro and I see what similar films
are who they're with and I just can't navigate
this can you help me yeah all the time because
there's there are a lot of different kinds of
people at AFM like they're sales agents versus
Distributors sometimes they do both there's been
increasing trend of some International sales
agents getting into U.S distribution their
contracts look a little bit different than what
U.S Distributors agreements look like and so yeah
I get it all the time that from filmmakers hey
they can't get the Distributors to call them back
there are some Distributors that are pretty good
have an open door policy of looking at lots of
material and there's some Distributors that just
want to really use the system of agents and Reps
that are out there to to kind of be a kind of a
buffer against all the content that's out there
they don't need to see 10 000 movies this year
they want to look at the top three or four hundred
which to choose the 20 they might distribute
that year so it just yeah most most filmmakers
when they go to FM AFM is a great learning
process but it's not a great really a great
tool for independent filmmaker to go to
and actually sell their own film it usually
they experience it once they'll they'll find
it's really hard to get in those doors to meet
with Distributors and most Distributors and sales
agents want to keep Keep the Wolves at Bay so to
speak of course so if a filmmaker says well I'm
very Hands-On and DIY I'll I'll be the one to
break through it's kind of like they're breaking
protocol a little bit that's not how it's yeah
it's well it's not that it's not okay it's just
that there are there are some companies that it's
just hard to get a return phone call they're
just busy dealing with the Reps and agents for
film and they're they're getting some of these
companies are getting five six submissions a day
and some of them they just completely
ignore they just look at it and think
I don't know what that is there's
just there's just too much in coming
so it helps to have someone that knows them
that says hey I can vouch this is something
you should take a look at it's not crazy for you
to look at this you may not like it you may love
it but it's something you should pay attention to
that's one aspect of it but it even more than that
there are some doors that it's they're easy to
get into but you shouldn't go through them right
there's some people that just don't have your best
interests at heart they're just there's a lot of
in my opinion companies that just don't do it
properly and take exorbitant fees don't cap
their costs don't do things that they should do
to to to help their the their client the filmmaker
maximize revenues for them as well as for the
company that took on the film so um yeah so
there's there's multiple reasons to have a rep
I think beyond just be able to get in the door
[Music] but I I've known there are also
people that make film after film after film
and establish relationships where they can just
do that themselves as well especially first time
second time filmmakers that have a hardest
time which are most independent filmmakers
at the end of the day of the of the 10 000 made a
year it's 9 000 plus they're either first timers
to a certain degree so it's not just helping
you get in the door it's also maybe helping
you stay away from doors that are open that yeah
shouldn't be venturing into for sure and and even
if you knew it's also maximizing the best possible
situation even if you get in all the right doors
it's helpful to have someone that's had a a deal
through this distributor and how to film through
this streamer and knows what it's like to be
in bed with them to knows how good are they at
communication how good are they return your phone
calls what are their royalty Reports look like
do they send them to you consistently
because it's not only the contract you
have to worry about it's the behavior behind
the contract right because it's fairly easy
for Distributors to kind of ignore a lot of
different aspects of their contract because
it's just the distribution contracts are just
hard to sue on they're all very distributor
friendly Distributors are not going to make
overtly producer-friendly contracts in general
so even more important than the contract is
is the habits and behavior and have been in
the business for 25 years I've just seen
a lot of a lot of behavior so to speak so
um I think that's pretty helpful sure and these
are these are contracts that only the distributor
draws up if someone couldn't say I've actually
have my own boiler plate yeah it's always a
new Distributors contract in fact you should be
actually wary if it's not their contract because
that probably indicates they don't know better
and they haven't been doing it very long I have
seen that before where I got it actually not too
long ago someone came to me with a film and they
already had an offer from someone and I said okay
did they have a did they send you a contract I
could look at for you and they said no they wanted
us to sit and do the contract as well there they
can't be that sophisticated if they if they're
out there acquiring films and wanting you to come
up with the contract that's just pretty pretty
it's a good sign that they're just not very savvy
Glenn how do you get paid please tell us a
couple different ways so always a commission
a percentage of whatever my filmmaker makes
so there's an advance from the distributor
or royalties paid later on I usually get
a commission on whatever and and that's
that's a negotiable commission depending on the
circumstances of the film whether it's already
in a major festival or if I'm working on from the
beginning we can negotiate what the commission is
often I also work for a consulting fee as
well because I spend most producer reps
I would say tend to throw films against the wall
see if they stick if they don't make the deal
move on I deal with very much true Independent
films that need a lot of hand-holding and a lot
of tender living care and so I fashion myself as
both kind of a producer rep and a consultant so
I'm usually paid an upfront fee in addition to
my commission really to help with the fact that
I'm going to negotiate the contract I'm going to
handle all that I'm going to spend time with them
to make sure they understand the industry
understand the buyers under help out maybe
getting them in their national sales agents so I
try to fashion myself as kind of a distribution
consultant and a producer rep are all your fees
like one-time fees or are there any that are
continual just one time one time was just one
time yeah it's usually an upfront fee and then
in the way I do it I don't I don't put a
term on my my deals I'm I feel like I'm
hired for however long it takes
me to get the film distribution
or a festival I'm also brought on as a festival
Advocate quite often so that's part of the the
fee structure is that I'm going to Advocate the
film to festivals programmers I've gotten to know
over time to try to help it get some kind of
promotional boost before we sell the film so
I've gotten to know a lot of programmers over the
years so sometimes I'm brought in pre-festival
to call programmers and just make
sure they're watching the movie
also to pitch it but I think the biggest thing
there is just to make sure they're watching it
if you add up the number of entries into
these festivals and you look at the number
of people that are been hired to watch them it's
almost impossible right that this few number of
people are watching this number of movies over a
three-month period so their films some films are
not getting watched or they're just being watched
by an intern or an underlying so I'm there to try
to make sure that someone of significance
is watching the movie and giving a chance
in addition to maybe Consulting
my filmmakers on what festivals
to apply to is it right for Sundance is
it a South by Southwest kind of movie
if not is it more of a Heartland Seattle there's
all kinds of great festivals but there's different
festivals of different strategies so I'm here
for that kind of in addition to everything
else have you ever had filmmakers say skip
the festivals I I I know it won't get into
this one and I won't get into that one and these
other ones I don't care as much about absolutely
and from an advisory point of view I've
even said that too to some people that
your film isn't right it's commercial
it's if you have a family movie right
Sundance doesn't take a lot of family films and
they have they I mean they might have a section
where they take like one or two really big family
films but they're not going to take small kind
of dog or Pony movies right those kind of movies
aren't right for festivals horror films in general
of a certain level don't there's a horror
audience out there that doesn't really
require kind of lift of a film festival to
to get it out there and to a certain degree
festivals really only add so much value these
days to a film festival the real value at least
pre-covered for me for of Sundance and South
by and Tribeca those are festivals that are
attended by buyers and so they're in a room
they're feeling the audience watch the movie
it's the only place where Distributors make
mistakes right where they where they like they
they get a feeling like okay let's go bid on the
movie off of this feeling they have in the theater
they're never gonna have that feeling when
they're watching the film on their cell
phone while they're driving or or however
they're they're watching your movie right
it's so those festivals in particular have
that in addition to some branding value
they also have the value of having
the people there watching the movie
there's another several thousand film festivals
in North America the buyers just don't go to
really great festivals and maybe one or two show
up because they're on a panel or something but
they're not flocking there to watch the content to
see if there's films to buy they know that at some
point those films will eventually get to them and
they'll be able to watch it in their office it's
not worth flying all over the country to see
these to these festivals and the so the value
to a distribute the value there is maybe if we
have a film that's not right for Sundance didn't
get Tribeca Etc but it goes to Seattle then we're
going to go into the distributor saying hey here's
this great movie and it just premiered in Seattle
check it out and you pitched the movie and then
they watch it and take you now now the fact that
it's in Seattle goes in one ear and out the other
right it's not a heavy consideration for them like
oh wow it played Seattle not the one with flux
Miguel all kinds of hate mail about Seattle but
Seattle is a great Festival but the buyers just
aren't there and so the Distributors are going
to watch it on Vimeo at that point or Blu-ray
so there's just there's just marginal value
for festivals at that point but there's lots
of other good reasons to go to festivals other
than will it get distribution because of them
it's the best experience you have with the
film usually experience it with an audience
it's better than theatrical per se where it's
which I feel it was kind of cold there's not
like a ready willing audience you go to limley
and you've there's five seats filled and it just
doesn't have the same impact as a as a festival
screening where people are there to to purposely
enjoy a film like they really want to enjoy
it and other reasons are to get feedback from
fellow filmmakers to see other people's
films to meet other people you might work
with in the future to maybe someone who wants
to invest in your next movie there's all sorts
of good things that come out of festivals but
really for setting up distribution there's it's
really minimal what what they what they provide
for that um so when I'm talking to filmmakers
I have to kind of deal with their expectations of
what they want to do and give advice on like how
to proceed strategically to get the film the
best possible position and usually I'm going
to say if it's not a Sundance or a South buyer
Tribeca kind of film we can go for vessels and
do that but at any time if you get tired of that
and you're like we haven't gotten to the festival
can we go ride the bars we can because it's only
providing a little bit of color to the fact that
you've got a good film already in my view so
and so when filmmakers do come to me and say
let's just go straight to buyers no problem really
no problem at all it's to a certain degree too
some I I've had there are places like
there's some streamer a couple of streamers
that I've approached the films before and they
once a film's in a festival they've already kind
of looked at it not not that they've seen the
film but they've kind of digested what it is
and made an assessment purely off of an image and
a synopsis we want to check that out or we don't
there's a lot they don't so I've had a little
bit more success with some films especially
documentaries if I'm going to them without
anything and saying hey this has not been exposed
anywhere in the world no festival or anything
I'm giving you and a few other people a look
at it first sometimes that's a better message
to a distributor than hey we played Seattle
because sometimes I'll get yeah we looked
we saw it in the listings not for us you'll
get sometimes then I've got to beg and plead
them to watch it and give it another chance so
yeah it's at the same time though lots of
filmmakers just want to play festivals right they
just that's just a thing and I very understandably
there's a lot of great stuff about it so
the I'm here to advise on strategy and then once
we've decided with the filmmaker what to do then
I'll implement it whatever kind of whatever they
want to do so they want to play festivals do they
also want to attend or some are okay getting into
these bigger festivals and not going yeah you get
different most I find want to attend and we're
talking pre-covet again before when you could but
most I find want to attend occasionally I'll
find someone who doesn't really care about going
but overwhelming 90 I think want to go and have
the experience of of the crowd and and all the
things that you get out of the film festival
yeah sure q a yeah those are great yeah yeah
absolutely right feeling the energy yeah what
red flag should a filmmaker look for if they
are considering hiring a producer rep well
so I would say look at all their go to IMDb
look at their history of all the films
that they've sold call those filmmakers
if dig in find a website address
if it's not rarely available get
to those people and and call them and
see what kind of experience they had
I imagine that all producer reps and Distributors
and sales agents all have people that don't like
them but hopefully you find someone that's got
more people that like them that don't like them
I think I I think when I when I pitch myself
for and I never really cognizant of like who
else they're looking at like I don't have a
sense of my competition that way it's never
like me against the same three guys for a film it
just doesn't it's fairly I find that I think most
films that I talk to about repping their films
aren't really considering many other options
that's the sense I get I don't really
ask them about it or really care
but I could say this so I know when I decide
to get into the business I was working for an
international sales agent at the time and looking
around the landscape I felt like there was a need
for someone to do what I do a little bit more
deeply than I felt like other producer reps
were doing it like I kind of alluded to before
there's a lot of just kind of okay toss it to
the wall if none of these 10 Distributors want it
moving on which leaves everybody empty and and so
I really try to do I I try to do the job of making
sure I understand the full distribution landscape
who are the best possible options for this film if
none of them want it what are the possible second
tier options for them to do I also have my own
tricks of the trade if something were to fall
to self-distribution per se what's the what
are the best practices there who's the best
aggregator to use those situations so I'm
I'm trying to I'm trying to provide a full
kind of Consulting service around what I
do as opposed to that so I I think that
when you're looking for a producer rep
it's kind of it's kind of like references
do you like the films they've sold in
the passage your film feel like a fit
have they made deals can you can they point to
films that have had deals with Netflix and Hulu
and Showtime and HBO and and IFC Etc but yeah
it's funny I should probably take another look
at the at the landscape of producer reps out there
besides myself and see what options people have to
to maybe give a fuller answer on that but yeah
to a certain degree aging that's probably the
the way to go about it why is your advice to
filmmakers to not make movies for money well
so it depends on the level of investment
of a film and what what my advice changes
film to film for sure and filmmaker to filmmaker
depending on their goals and what they're doing so
if you want to make if your passion is
to make a film about growing mushrooms
and you want to spend an hour and a half just
watching the mushrooms grow you shouldn't tell
the investor you need 150 000 to shoot that
movie and it'll get on Netflix for sure right
but if you can go out and do it for your own
pocket change and you can do it on your iPhone
and then you can put it in an art museum
okay great that's your passion that you
had a founder and interesting way to film those
mushrooms right the point there is I guess that
if you make something low budget and because it's
your and it's your passion and everybody knows
the high risk of whatever you're spending
then great everybody's going in Eyes Wide Open
But ultimately most films just monetarily fail
overwhelmingly fail and that's not because of
Distributors being crooked although
there's a little of that in places
not because they spend too much money advertising
or putting in their pockets or have exorbitant
deals it's because there's overwhelming amount
of content out there for consumers to consume
and just no way to monetize every independent
film that everybody makes in in a way that
makes sense vis-a-vis the budget I I'm in
the position of seeing the the results for
intimately of over a thousand films in 25 years
and overwhelmingly the most films fail that's just
that's just the reality Marketplace if you look at
not to name names but if you look at a decent Art
House distributor one of the ones that distributes
20 to 25 films a year and has a prominent brand
and well thought of and everybody wants to be with
if you look at their box office for each of the
films that year there are a couple that get over a
million dollars and there's about 20 that make 200
to a few thousand dollars and they've spent money
to try to make those films into something and it
just didn't work right so that's why everyone
should approach filmmaking as the business
with a huge amount of caution because it's it's
better to put your film in a mutual your buddy
in a future mod sorry your money in a mutual fund
right it's not a film is not a great investment um
um and so if you are making a film for in the
two to three million dollar range there are ways
to go about it without just taking someone's
cash and blowing it that to amortize the risk
or to minimize the risk you can shoot in an estate
with a tax credit like to take care of 25 at 30
percent of the budget so narrowing how much the
person has to spend in cash on the film there's
getting involved with a international sales agent
and getting cast that they can sell the film on
to to pre-sell the film so that you can take
those contracts and Cat and get cash for those
from a bank in order to squeeze down the amount
of equity you have to spend so there are ways to
minimize it so that you've let's say you've made
a two million dollar film and you now all you need
in equity is 25 of the budget you're making a two
million dollar film essentially for half a million
dollars now hopefully with the name that you've
got and the quality of the film you made when
you're when it's done you'll be able to present
it to the territories you did pre-sell and get
numbers that are bigger than that half a million
but you're still risking that half million dollars
if it turns out badly it's gone there's just only
so many films a year that Distributors who can pay
a million dollars plus for a film are gonna buy
like I said there's like 10 000 films made a year
and big the biggest Distributors that actually
take on indie films only won a couple of them
companies a little a little lower down what 20 25.
the ones are doing real theatrical films a year
there's some that want 10 to 20. and
then there are there's a a good number of
I would call kind of mostly all rights
just digital Distributors who sometimes
do theatrical as well but most of them
aren't paying a lot of money for films so
you know we are looking at the film as a business
you have to realize it's hardly even a business
it's practically throwing money away and the thing
that Studios and and bigger Distributors know is
that not they know all films are not going to work
so they're but they're they're playing the long
game of making multiple films over the course of a
year and that they know that the winners will pay
for the losers over time as independent filmmaker
one making one movie you're taking one shot and
that makes it even a higher risk so
going back to the argument of [Music]
don't try to make money from the film this
it seems like it's an interesting thing in
that do you make it for the market and try to
try to cash in on it or do you make it based
on something you're really passionate about
but then is it going to be marketable yeah
that's tough I think you have you have to look
to the individual and their soul and what they're
about at the end of the day right and there
are some people that how is they have it all
they have the talent they have something they're
very passionate about that that is let's say it's
a dramatic story that isn't a thriller or horror
or family film it's not obviously commercial but
they've just really they've written it well people
responded to on the page actors are responding to
on the page financiers are responding on
the page and then it all comes together
and it becomes this great thing that does well
it sells the Netflix or sells to a big company
that can happen but those are very rare
occurrences so I think all filmmakers
have to kind of Juggle that stuff some people
also inherently have commercial sensibilities
and they grew up loving Spielberg and and and
Ron Howard and people and who people who had
commercial sensibilities and they tell this
kind of instinctively tell commercial stories
there's some people that don't they go
they're more Fellini fans or truffaut or
someone like and that's what the
way they see the world but they
and probably having those influences is going to
make the way they tell stories a little different
and so that has to be kind of brought to the
mix of like how old is this how is this Talent
converge with what's commercial I don't think it's
ever really good to make a movie because well it's
the right genre and we've got the right name but
the town the director's okay and the screenplay
is okay right that's okay maybe they'll trade
dollars because they could pre-sell the movie and
get some money based on the name and it gets an
okay deal but it's probably just trading dollars
at the end of the day it's probably not gonna the
film's probably not gonna lift beyond that I think
there you have to take into consideration kind
of everything in this business when you're making
a film again depending on the budget again if
you're going out and spending ten thousand dollars
on your little movie go crazy right like you're
you're only risking your own ten thousand dollars
and there are there are lots of people doing
that and that's that's fine right as long as you
understand that like you're probably not getting
a hundred thousand dollar HBO deal out of that
so cursed are the ones that want
to do a movie on shiitake mushrooms
with Organic Soil and and but you never know
if it's just the greatest mushroom yeah only
cursed if they think that they're they're gonna
get a Netflix deal out of it right okay if it's
if it's okay that they make it and show it
in an art museum perfectly legitimate right
there's an audience there there are people that
like avant-garde interesting experimental things
but you don't see that stuff on
the major streamers You Don't See
even IFC Magnolia a24 they're not picking up
avant-garde stuff or just even or weird stuff I
mean if you look at most their slates it's fairly
commercial stuff even though it's you know high
brow and has interesting filmmakers a lot of them
you look at genre a lot a lot of those films are
Thrillers and horror films they're just elevated
in some way right a good portion of them none of
those guys are doing like 25 dramas a year the
market wouldn't bear it for them it wouldn't work
yeah I don't know why this keeps coming into my my
mind right now but Searching for Sugar Man which
was such an excellent film I know some people were
critical of it I loved it but it was able to sort
of transcend I mean it it won an Academy Award
correct or yeah I think so yeah yeah and and so
here here's a story that seems kind of unlikely
and it was just so beautifully told and the the
main character yeah so fascinating and there
are anomalies right so this is like but you
just don't build a business which is each film is
almost a business at a certain budget level right
you can't you can't build a business based on
an anomaly right you have to you should you
should look at genre you should look at cast you
should look at those things depending on what your
budget level is there's certain budget levels
you can't afford cast right you can't afford
names that will work on your film unless you're
uncle is Tom Cruise like then then you're you're
most likely not casting someone that that helps
prop up the movie so I think you have to factor
in cast and genre in your budget in addition
something I don't think enough people do is
vet their screenplay with get 100 people to read
it get script services to read it get feedback
there's so many so many films that I have to turn
down that I think wow is really well shot and
and the acting's competent but there's
just no story here or there's just not
enough of the story or I didn't get the
story fast enough there's certain kind
of rules of screenwriting you kind of have to
follow in order to make a a commercial movie
this is a hard topic for us to bring up but I'm
hoping maybe you can clear up some misconceptions
we often hear that filmmakers aren't making money
from distribution deals but at the same time we
hear that you can make great money working in
distribution can you can you help us understand
here well yes so in my opinion most people aren't
making money from distribution because most films
just don't work because the public didn't decide
to click on your movie they didn't buy a ticket
there's just a lot more there's just
a lot more content being created by
the streamers and by Studios that and and we've
got other ways of entertaining ourselves in
movies these days games and TikTok and whatever
that is there's just not a lot of as much demand
as there's not a lot of demand compared to the
supply at the end of the day and so I find that
and distributors are in the job of taking
a certain a certain number of films a year
they know that some are going to work they
know by experience not all of them are going
to work and they're going to do about the same
thing on every film maybe treating one a little
better a little bit more p a more advertising
dollars behind it in order to make it work
and and they're good so they're gonna take each
one out and if one doesn't work it's going to
then go through the motions of trying to get
a team if it didn't work in Theatrical and or
transactional VOD like iTunes and Amazon where
people can rent and buy it it didn't work there
they're still going to try to sell it to HBO or
Hulu if they can if it doesn't work there then
they're going to put it on Advertising video man
demand channels like two beer Pluto that pay small
royalties per view right and that's what most
that's the windowing that most Distributors do
and there's not a lot to that right it's just
placement at the salesmanship and placement and
they're not going to spit like if a film didn't
work in the very beginning they're not going
to keep spending advertising dollars they're
going to keep there's not much for them to do
and I think filmmakers feel like hey you're not
doing anything for my movie well but should they
be doing anything for your movie if they did more
for your movie they would probably lose more money
if the film didn't work on the outset if it didn't
connect in the first three months of its life
it's it's not going to make money and that's
and it's going to stay with that distributor
as they're going to put it through the platforms
properly but if they were to spend more time and
effort trying to monetize it they would lose and
you wouldn't make any more money is the reality
in addition I think in general Distributors
are pretty bad at communicating that
two filmmakers I constantly am
having to preach that on their behalf
to my clients and other people in the business
because all I've gone on to there's platforms out
there where people vent about distribution right
and I see who they're who they're venting about
and I know the I know and some yes there are
some there there are some scumbags out there
that no one should ever go near but there are
some people they're venting about on there
that I know are running honest businesses and
doing it properly but they're just not going to
be your best friend forever right they're
not gonna be the best friend of the film
forever they're just gonna do their job
if it works great if it doesn't it doesn't
I also find some some filmmakers just don't
understand their contracts when they get into them
there are some Distributors of a certain
level that are saying okay we're gonna put
the film out theatrically we're going to spend
this amount of money and here's a big check
and that's that's great forget about that for
a second but most deals are with Distributors
that are not putting up any money and just
going to take it out on the various digital
platforms and try to sell off Netflix and Hulu
later Etc and in those cases many filmmakers
just don't understand that that's what they're
getting into they think I got a distributor my
life is saved my film is going to make a lot of
money and they're going to Market it without even
talking to them about marketing and sometimes
these countries even literally say we're not
hiring a publicist we're not marketing the film
we have the option to but we're not pledging to
and so if you go in thinking you're going to do
one thing and they don't do it then there's then
you're getting on some platform and saying oh I
hate so and so and so that's why I I see a lot of
that that's not to diminish the people that do
get screwed over there are there are companies
there are Bad actors out there but there are
a lot of Distributors that just I think a are
doing the job properly if if even if they are
falling a little short on the communication of
why the films are not working to their clients so
it's kind of a barring someone being dishonest if
a company is honest but but then you have a
filmmaker a over here who feels like I'm not
being given attention and my movie's just being
shoved to the back it sounds like there's just
the communication is just really broken and
one is a business person the other is kind of
an artist that's very possessive over their their
work yeah and they're not meeting in the middle
yeah I think that's right and I think and that's
not to say I wish that Distributors could be a
little bit more communicative and a little bit
more in kind of in general even the ones I like
could be a little bit more um responsive to phone
calls and emails from clients but I think to a
certain degree a lot of these companies are taking
a lot of films and they've got to kind of move on
to the things that work and not all filmmakers are
are personable nice people either right you get
some filmmakers that have screws loose or are have
Napoleonic complexes or whatever they have and
and and they're coming after them with phone call
after phone call day after day as a distributor
like do I have to deal with that or I don't
I don't have a contractual obligation to call
back a jerk right I'm going to move on and start
working I'm working just like I do any other film
whether he's a jerk or not I'm going to do the
same thing right I'm just going to stop talking
to him because he's just wasting my time right
now most filmmakers aren't like that but there
are that does happen and I think that because
that happens that it also makes distributors
a little bit more reticent to be personable and
and and and and communicate with their filmmakers
in case it turns into that kind of like like why
am I on this conversation with this person who
I I put their film out it's not making me
any more money to talk to them about what's
happening yes they're my client but what what is
there to do at this point and the reality too is
hard about this too is that some of these
contracts are seven ten years long right and
so filmmakers quite often feel stuck they're
like they're not doing anything with my movie
and I can't get it back well the problem
there is what do you do when you get it back
you knocking no other distributor is going to take
it after it's been distributed by somebody else
you're not going to be able to get Netflix or Hulu
or so so and so to look at it most likely they've
already shown it to them and they've passed if you
get it back if they do agree if they do agree to
give it back to you have to get extracted from
all these digital platforms that it's on they
can't just turn the hose over to you and have the
financials just start go you have to pull it off
and then you have a hard time getting
it back on because some of those some
of those platforms are like we've had this film
before it acts like like we don't want old films
[Music] and so it's and so people end up putting
on Amazon Prime or to kind of direct themselves
and it just sits there and doesn't make any money
anyway so most filmmakers should be if they can
moving on to the next thing at that point what's
my next project how can I take whatever Happened
Here make some good out of it and hype it towards
getting my next thing done because once you've got
once you've made that distribution deal whether
you're in a good situation or a bad situation
you're that's it that's your your film is is
that's going to be the story of your film one way
or the other yeah it's kind of an illusion that
you can get it back at some point and and make
something out of it and that's why in addition
to knowing who the buyers are and being able
to read and understand contracts isn't that's
kind of where I come in I know who communicates
well I know who does the job properly and what
that job actually is as opposed to what it is
and can explain that to the filmmakers so they
know what they're getting into when we make the
deal so we don't get those calls two years later
saying why aren't they marketing my film because
they knew about going in because I explained it
to them exactly what kind of situation they got
well you use the word illusion which I thought's
fitting because maybe they did read the contract
maybe you explained that to them properly but
there's an illusion mine's going to be different
I realize it's going to be locked up for the but
this is different yeah and there's nothing against
the filmmaker it's just we all think our thing
is 100 I've I've produced movies as well with
other not myself alone but with other people and
and I've I've gotten the spell I've been in the
bubble of like we made the greatest thing ever
this is going to go to whoever and so I unders
I do understand that and I do have and I do have
clients that despite I explain it to them do come
back to me later and say like why aren't they
doing this and like well if you remember this
is what we talked about it's not quite like that
for this film should a filmmaker kind of take
the worst case scenario I know some people don't
like to operate like that but it can help if you
kind of take the worst case scenario stance you're
looking at the contract and thinking well I know
it says I'll be locked up in this territory
whatever for seven years but I'm sure it'll
be fine and maybe just have something in their
mind do I really want that is this really for me
um I think that yes I think that I think
you can make an educated guess on what the
worst case will be based on the habits of the
company you're in bed with to a certain degree
so because most distribution agreements don't have
anything in them that says they have to put out
the movie either right sometimes we can build in
Clauses where it says if you don't release it in
nine months we'll get the movie back but that's
pretty easy to fulfill I can throw it on Amazon
and it's released per se right so it's hard to
get a distribute like a narrow get a distributed
guarantee what will happen I'm saying that because
if you are if you do get a deal with a distributor
and you look back on the last couple of years
and you see oh they've released all these films
and these this is how they've released them
there's a little more security that the worst
case scenario is that they're going to release
it like that right they said they're going to
put it on all these platforms they did it for all
these other films so that's most likely the worst
case scenario and the worst case scenario is that
they do that and no one bothers to buy the movie
that can happen for lots of films it doesn't
happen at a certain level if you're getting big
theatrical deals but we're talking about straight
to digital distribution that's very much but it's
it's funny because I've had so many films now
go to these Distributors that handle all rights
and give them the same treatment and some make
a couple hundred thousand dollars and some make
two thousand dollars and you really can't see any
difference between the two except that perhaps the
artwork just clicked with the public better the
trailer clicked someone said something about it
kind of organically online and that took off and
created a swirl it's really hard like there's a
lot of things you can tell a filmmaker to try to
do to support a film publicity get in a social
media company doing a theatrical there's nothing
that guarantees that any of that will help or work
almost always do kind of if someone just has
has a a digital distribution deal say try to
do something to help support it because
at least you feel like you did something
but there's no real empirical evidence that like
having a publicist for a film makes a dollar more
or that running five thousand dollars in
social media ads makes ten dollars more
at least from what I see in terms of looking
at films I've seen many films get no treatment
make lots of money and some don't we posted
a poll on our YouTube Community Tab and the
question was do you trust film Distributors
so the poll received about 8 000 or so votes
and 85 percent of those polled said they do not
trust Distributors oh now we didn't ask them in
what capacity they've dealt with them where do
you think this negative reputation stems from
it all goes to the the failure rate of films
and I think that I think some Distributors
oversell what will happen to films in
order to get them not all but some do
I think it goes to expectations of just getting
a distribution deal and thinking hey I'm done
it's going to make make money I think that's
part of it I think it's frustrating to have
Gatekeepers to the public there's there there
are so many things coming out of a dollar
before it gets to you as the filmmaker
because someone buys the film on iTunes
iTunes is taking 30 percent all right that's 70
is going to your distributor your distributor is
taking 25 and costs so when they get by costs
then they're paying you at that point right so
there's there's a lot of international sales
your International sales companies taking 20
percent they're putting it with a distributor
overseas is going to take their percentage
that distributor is putting on a digital platform
that's going to put it and make money in Germany
or wherever so there's three steps before it
gets gets to you so if it were the case that
and is the case that people could go and
put film you do have the ability to go put
the film on digital platforms yourself so
there are Labs that have kind of aggregator
kind of call themselves aggregators although I
think the word aggregator is kind of a strange
word for it but all they're really doing is
facilitating placing the film on Amazon iTunes
Google Play Etc and they're you're paying them the
cost of encoding the phone for the platform but
they're not taking a percentage at all so you're
iTunes is taking 30 and you're getting 70 percent
the reason why and now maybe some films should
do that because they could just it's a small film
and they can push people to watch on iTunes and
then they get what they they reap what they sow
the reason people go to Distributors as opposed
to doing it themselves is Distributors can get to
more platforms than these Labs can there
are some platforms that require a pitch
so to get a film on in demand DirecTV dish Etc
you need someone to go and Pitch the movie to them
and then when it comes out on iTunes and Amazon
Etc it's going to be the release date is going to
be the same for those platforms in addition these
Distributors have relationships with streaming
companies like Netflix and Hulu and HBO so once
they have the film in the transactional VOD world
they're then going to go try to make that sell
if you go put your phone on iTunes you can't
there's no way to get into Netflix at that
point even I can't go to Netflix I I can go
to Netflix originals division as a producer
rep but I can't go to them in a distributor
position of where it is after it's been on
transactional for a while so if we lived in
a world where all these platforms were open to
filmmakers going there that's what we would do
and I would I would become a marketing expert
instead I would help people with marketing
and just say hey let's just go put in these
platforms but there are Gatekeepers to those
platforms or people have those relationships
and that's the reason we have to use them
and then there are some people that
treat that space honorably and understand
are respectful of the fact they got lucky enough
to be in such a position to be the Gateway for
other people's content and treat their filmmakers
well and explain everything to them and try to do
the best and then there are some that really just
take it and never call you back and that's that's
for I think it kind of goes back to communication
I think at the end of the day there's just if if
Distributors did a better job of communicating
on the front end what's going to happen what
the what what's likely what's realistically the a
medium outcome or the best outcome and in addition
we're a little bit more open as filmmakers came
back to them with questions about how it's going
and explain what why they were doing
what they were doing I think if they
were better at that in general that
poll number would be a little bit better
although I think the the main reason for it is
just most films fail and and therefore who we're
going to blame I'm not gonna blame my movie
my movie is perfect right like I it's my baby
and the person who adopted my baby is not
raising it properly and but but yeah I think
but that's hard that's hard for them to do it's
it's and then you're dealing with corporations
and Distributors are not individuals and
so you've got the director of Acquisitions
the director of sales the director of
delivery the CFO the accounting department
and they all have their own Lanes of what they
kind of deal with and as the filmmaker like oh
so who do I talk to about the fact that this
doesn't look right or I want I don't Amazon
my poster on Amazon looks a little weird
or whatever and sometimes it's hard to
navigate because not all companies have
a front person that's just like kind of
the the go-to for the client to say okay
you got this problem talk to this person
I think part of this is like economics like
they just don't have the bandwidth to have
that many employees at the end of the day and
take the they they do the math of like we need
to take this number of films we can make this
amount of money and so we've got a stretch our
employees to do this number of jobs they're just
not going to get Royal Treatment like they want
and then there's also the the sort of thought of
that filmmakers or artists and their work is kind
of never done so they're probably tweaking
the poster art maybe the log line different
things and then they're making all these changes
and submitting it and then you're dealing with
business people who don't have the time maybe to
to hand hold all these subsequentions I mean I'm
sure that probably happens a little bit and
then they feel like they're being ignored and
maybe in some cases they are being ignored and
others it's just their demands are so high yeah
yeah I don't know if I I don't see a lot
of people still tinkering after the fact
it's usually the T It's usually the case that
they have to at some point they have to okay
I'm done and let it and let it go creatively at
least in terms of log line or trailer or things
like that I don't see a lot of people where
I see it breaking down is much more in terms
of like well what's happening you're like are
you trying to sell Netflix like I haven't heard
anything and most Distributors just don't care
about communicating that the They Don't Really
they feel like we're doing our job we're going to
pay you what you do but we don't need to explain
to you what we're saying to Netflix or when
we're going to talk to Netflix or or any of that
I just feel like Distributors probably
don't feel like they have the time in a
day to talk to all their filmmakers about all the
intricacies of everything they do is my best guess
best guess from being on the outside
looking in a lot but never really been in
at the same time what type of accounting
practices should a filmmaker expect when
working with a distributor so overwhelmingly
most Distributors offer quarterly accountings
and that's that's pretty standard to at least
get two or three years of quarterly and then
and then turns the biannual after that
or annual sometimes and that's when your
most of your revenue is gonna that's what it
really counts the most the frustrating thing
with accounting is that Distributors are on
accounting terms as well with the platforms
so a lot of times people get their first quarter
statement and they're rated okay let's see how we
did and it's not there's not much there and that's
partly because when I go and buy a film on Amazon
keeps that money for 90 days before it
hits the bank account of your distributor
and so if it's March and I paid for in March
it's not going to hit the distributor until June
and that's the second quarter so even though
someone paid for something in the first quarter
the distributor didn't get it until the
second quarter and so that's when they're
going to account for it usually anywhere
from 30 to 90 days after the quarter
so it takes a long time for stuff to come
in and that's frustrating I wish it was more
I wish it was unfortunately that's what makes
it hard to do anything in social media to try
to help the cause because you can if you buy ads
and stuff for lots of products out there you can
kind of see what it does for you right and if you
spend ten thousand dollars on Facebook ads you can
see what the return is on whatever you're selling
pretty quickly because you're the one selling it
but in film you you do the advertisement and
you're waiting six months to find out whether
Amazon anybody bought the film on Amazon and
then your past really the period so that's
makes the whole business so hard because
you just don't the companies that dominate
the space in terms of where people buy movies
Can can dictate the terms of how they account
even to the distributors so you're saying that
a filmmaker reasonably most contracts would say
every quarter you're getting a statement for two
years and then after that it's biannually and then
annually yeah okay so then if they have nine
years then toward the latter end of it they're
going to be getting yearly statements correct and
some it depends on the distributor because some
distributors are more amenable to changing their
basic terms than others so it kind of depends but
some Distributors will say well eventually
if we if we don't collect anything we're
not going to account so there's zero coming in
there's no reason to send you a piece of paper
that says zero came in sometimes we try to add
language that says you're going to count to this
regardless because I want you to be accountable
per se so it yeah can depend on the distributor
just as a film's budget impact what it'll
sell for let's say someone makes a film for
half a million is a distributor likely
to make an offer of half a million no
in fact they don't care what the budget is they
may care from the point of view of Interest like
oh how if they're know anything about production
and they think oh wow you really this looks
great what did you spend from that perspective the
distributors in general they want to all they care
about is what it's worth on the market and they're
going to look at your film and compare it to other
films in their catalog or in their imagination or
wherever they however they make their subjective
evaluation of your film and decide okay we
think once it goes out into the world it'll make
we think it will make a million dollars then they
might be advancing and they really have to think
it it's going to make a million dollars in order
to advance half a million dollars because there's
still gonna be costs for them to especially if
there's if there's if they're if they're buying
something for half a million dollars their price
spending a couple million dollars to monetize that
thing they can't just you buy something for half
a million dollars you can't just put it on the
on transactional VOD and hope to sell it later
films don't make that much money when you do that
so it's it's all about what what how much revenue
do we feel like this can make for us or how many
viewers do we feel like or how many subscribers
are we going to gain because of this this title
that's the way Netflix and Hulu and people like
that look at it because at the end of the day
I've seen half a million dollars films that look
like they were made for two dollars I've seen half
a million dollars films that look like they were
made for seven million dollars so that goes to the
talent of the production company and the filmmaker
and the ability to get value from what they spent
why do we hear that it's bad for filmmakers
to be transparent about their budget
so with regard to being transparent to a
distributor I think that if it's because it could
go you they could go badly two different ways if
I tell a distributor I made it for half a million
dollars their opinion would be like wow that was
ridiculous like why did you spend so much money
and then make them make them afraid of making
an offer because if you're expecting to make
that much money back they may not feel like
you even even though they're maybe the best
option for you they may feel conservatively that
they're not going to make that much money for you
on the flip side if they're if they're wowed
by it it doesn't I don't think it really makes
much difference from them unless
they're the kind of company that
is in the business of making films themselves
and are looking at you as a potential
filmmaker to invest in in the future and there are
very few Distributors actually most distributors
don't do that most servers are just Distributors
and so they don't really the budget just doesn't
really matter to them but it might matter to some
some Distributors that that actually make movies
well it's interesting because it seems like
with Hollywood we know their budget and it's
out there in the trades whereas with independent
filmmakers we're almost supposed to hide ours like
in a shameful way yeah I I usually just take the I
take the position of not being hiding it for shame
I just like why does it make any difference right
like unless you made it for ten thousand dollars
and it looks like half a million and you want to
brag about it and make that kind of part of your
your pitch that look how great we are we
could make something short but not I don't
find most Hollywood cares about that or and
I think that story's been played right we had
Robert Rodriguez and a couple of others that
have like wow this film was made for nothing
and now people tons of people make films for
nothing every day someone made a film for
almost nothing so it's no longer really
a badge of honor it's just another fact
and not a very sexy one way or the other I don't
think so I tend to sell people that's just not
they're not going to ask us so let's not put it
out there this is the way the way I see it I think
it's irrelevant like look at the quality of the
film if you want it pay the right price for it
but why is it different for Hollywood why
are we okay knowing the this many million
was spent on this film well there again I'm not
depending on the Hollywood film because there's
different there's Studio level and then there's
things that are kind of made with International
sales agents that pop up to Studio level and
so there's different kinds of Studio films
I'm not sure we're getting the accurate budget
from from these people even though they're public
sometimes so I think there's also there's been
a number of times and the number got out that
a production spent and it was so much that it
had a negative impact on people viewing the film
probably would have failed anyway but there's
a few out there that spent 200 million and be
people were like wow that that they
shouldn't have done that all right so
yeah mishtar Johnny Depp Native American
Film played Tonto oh Lone Ranger there
are a few examples out there of how it
negatively impacted the the publicity so
I think some of the some of the numbers
you see about Hollywood production stuff
out there is guessing really guesswork and
some ins getting some in-flight information
but that they're not necessarily publishing every
budget for everybody to see I don't think that's
that's really happening can you give us the ranges
of how much movies make on various platforms
well I can tell you from kind of
a true Indie perspective right
because I work on a mostly true indie films not
made in Hollywood not made with International
sales agents not made with Kevin Bacon in
it those are the films I mostly work on
um and I see the range of Revenue
coming off of transactional VOD
which is rental and buying on iTunes and
Amazon and the various cable TV platforms
straight to digital no theatrical the range
is kind of zero almost zero to 150 000 about
in that range with the median being much closer to
zero and the outliers at the 150 range so it's not
like the average is 75. the average is the media
the median is more like 20 000 I'd say 30 000 for
most most films and sorry to interrupt this is for
the life of the term of the contract correct okay
and most of that Revenue coming in within
the first two years and then just dropping
the next window they go to then of course
is s voter TV sales and the range there is
not making that deal so there's
zero coming in off of that window
to a couple hundred thousand dollars
with most films not getting that deal
that's probably the most likely case to some
films getting 40 to 20 to 60 in that range
and then AVOD [Advertising-based Video
on Demand] is a growing sorry advertising
video on demand which is to be in Pluto where
they're paying royalty people are watching
because and watching advertisement
rather than subscribing or paying for it
those platforms are paying 10 to 15 cents
per view and the revenues on there are
again kind of zero to 150 000 in that range as
well and growing because it's it's a growing
part of the business because a lot of people
don't want to pay there's a lot of people who
don't have money to subscribe to 10 platforms let
alone one and don't want to rent movies but watch
a lot of stuff in that in that in that ecosystem
now so it's a growing Growing Place for films to
make money and you can't skip Those ads correct
they're not skipping that's right that's right and
they come up in weird awful places right as well
it's not the best view to experience and you said
15 cents per is it per view it's purview what if
they if they watch a decent amount of the film I
think it's if they watch most of the movie then
the royalty paid out is can be 15 cents per view
which is a lot better than what Amazon Prime
went down to which is one cent per view
so that's been but we don't know where that's
going to go because there are more there are
many more AVOD platforms out there lots of
Distributors are creating their own AVOD
platforms advertising video on demand platforms
and and it just depends the Tubi was bought by Fox
and the way these things go you just never know
what they're going to do with the platform do
they keep it being a place where Distributors can
put all their stuff or do they eventually turn
into something else like Netflix at one point
was the place where you watched all the movies
you ever could right like it had every movie
now you go to watch Netflix content on Netflix
mostly so so we'll see is that purview per like
IP address if the same user is watching things
over and over again it can still generate money
yeah I'm not sure about that I'm I imagine that
the system probably has safeguards against
people creating algorithms so that they just
can just like play a film over and over again
and make it money right I'm sure that they
have safeguards against that but I don't know
for sure when you're reviewing a movie that a
potential client has sent you are you watching
the whole movie yeah if I unless I it isn't very
good yeah so you have a limit yo yeah oh yeah
yeah if I if I enjoy it I I watch it all the way
through and and then if I if I'm hired I usually
watch it again before I start talking about it
because usually there's a few weeks between that
moment and when I actually start doing it so I'm
usually watching my films twice and but yeah
I think that's there are a lot of films though
where you just kind of like I can't sell it like
why why why you know within 10 minutes there are
lots of out of focus stuff for the acting's
really bad or there's a lot of bad movies
out there that no one ever sees that that I I get
to watch a little bit of that was my next question
yeah what would make you turn it off after I we
have five minutes but okay let's say 10 minutes
so you give it do you have a rule like I'll give
it a certain amount of time and then yeah it's
it's more instinctive it's a more it's I I don't
I don't think anybody out of the circle of friends
of the person who made the movie would doubt
why I got out like it's that there's a lot of
well I should say though there's also
stuff I just don't think there's a home for
and if it's like the hardest category is is drama
without names and if you found an interesting way
to tell the story then then and it works and
we think there's a home for it then great but
that I find is probably the hardest to pull
off and if if you haven't like grabbed me
in the first 10 minutes you're probably not a
grab distributor who has less patience than me
and so I probably can't help you but I think I I
mean I think I probably that's for some films but
there are some films I watch all the way through
and then make that same decision that like well
I got there but it was torturous right like her or
in some way I just couldn't I just don't feel like
I could help them and what do you tell filmmakers
that fall into that category the truth yeah I
without being mean about it with just
saying hey I thank you for sharing the movie
it's not it's not right for me I just don't
feel like I could sell it and maybe there's
someone out there for you and here
maybe give them some other people
that there's a there's a website out there with
a bunch of producer reps on it and I usually say
check out that and maybe there's another way for
you or in some some people are also very nice it
also especially if they're very nice people and
they made a bad movie that's really hard and so
I'll even get on the phone with them and talk to
them about self-distribution and what they maybe
could do themselves that might be the best option
because I don't think that there's a distributor
would take it on so I'll have that conversation
with people once in a while are there individuals
who will fight you on it and say you didn't give
it a chance or they'll kind of like negate your
issues that you have with it yeah but not often
yeah there have been get all types of people for
sure I've had some movies I've watched a couple
movies because I've watched thousands of movies
a couple movies where I watched the film and I
really wondered about the sanity of the person who
made the movie not a good way like a razor head
or something like that but in a really disturbing
like what is this weird thing that someone sent
me and I don't want to talk to them at all that's
happened a couple times but that's pretty and I've
had a couple I've had a few people who are like
who make the pitch that like this is better
you think I'm like well then I'm sure you'll
find a home is it hard for you to tell
people no no I am it's part of the job
I think I think it's to be honest and my
mission in general is to help filmmakers
get the best possible distribution and if I
extend that to everyone even to not my clients
and the best message for them is you should
distribute this yourself because I don't think
a distributor will take it on I think if I've
got an obligation to share that message and
it's much it's actually easier than than saying
oh it's really good but I can I don't know how
to make stuff up I don't know I wouldn't know
how to how to how to fake that well in some
ways you might be helping them because then if
they're getting the same notes then if they make
another project they'll try to correct right yeah
yeah 100 percent would you rather a filmmaker
send you their trailer or the entire film the
whole film I like to see the whole thing um
um usually almost I don't know if I've ever
turned a film down off of a trailer I don't
think I have and quite often people will send
me a trailer when they when they reach out to me
and then I'll say hey looks good can I see the
whole movie but I almost like to see the whole
thing before I talk to someone as well so I
get a feeling for what they have sometimes
people want to talk ahead of time and I just
feel it's a bit of a waste of time because
yeah I don't know if I know if I can help
you yet I don't know what to tell you yet
and then it becomes just a free tutorial like
about the business where I don't mind that
but I prefer to be afterwards let's do it in
one shot rather than several so do you have a
preferred method for for watching something or
do you have it just playing on another screen
I throw up I've I most people send vimeulinks
and I usually throw them up on my big screen
TV to watch them I have a little quirk in that I
like to when I go to buyers with films if we're
not pushing them to a theater it's it's South
by Southwest or if we're just sharing it with
them directly there are some Distributors I like
to to send a Blu-ray as opposed to a female link
not all of them will do it some would prefer to
give me a link but there are some that are open
to getting my Blu-ray and then I prefer that a
little bit because I'm forcing them to watch it
on something bigger than than than their phone
because I know some of them do I haven't seen
it personally that someone watched it on their
phone but given that you can I imagine that like
if you're an Acquisitions executive and you've got
five films to watch that day and you're at lunch
you might pop one on your phone just to get just
to get through it and then it's not that's not the
most illegitimate thing to do given that if you're
a straight to digital Distributors lots of people
watching these things on small screens so they
may feel like they can but I just feel like in
general if I'm trying to like get someone to take
on a movie I'm usually trying to encourage them
to watch on something bigger just so they have a
better experience than than something like an iPad
you mentioned that you occasionally will watch
a string of bad movies here and there how many
movies do you feel like you have to go through
to get to one that really piques your interest
it's probably well first of all I the
number of clients come to me from referrals
either from agencies because they think hey
it's too small for for us and they recommend me
and they usually don't recommend me unless it's
someone they think there's a possibility of me
taking it on I get referrals from from just kind
of being out there in the world for a long time
and so the referral the the
the the rate of which I take films
on for referrals is quite High
because those have been
curated to a certain degree
and there's but from the the cold ones the ones
that come in cold to me I probably have to watch
10 to find one that I feel like I can work on
it's about that ratio how do you handle it when
a producer comes to you and they expect to make
let's say a million dollars off a film with a half
a million dollar budget so I'm always measuring
expectations with potential clients because
I don't really want to work with someone that
that expects something that's not going to happen
especially if they're gonna blame me
for it after the fact right like hey
I you I told you I needed to get a million
dollars and you didn't get a million dollars
so I'm always very careful to kind of explain how
much films in general make in the marketplace what
the percentage chances are for getting a deal
with a streamer what the percentage chances
are for getting with one of these all rights
Distributors and what they do and then even once
you get that deal because there's a it's never
100 because it's subjective and we don't know
then what here's the range of Revenue you could
potentially get and they have to be comfortable
with that because I'm gonna I'm gonna tell them
what the range of revenue is and so usually
there have been cases where it got past me and I
didn't like somehow we didn't communicate about
the number that they thought they were going to
get and then after the fact they're like I thought
this would make this and I'm like I don't know how
you would have thought that we went through all
this discussion about why that's not possible and
like you said some people just Harbor that thing
in the back of my wall of mine will be different
I don't care what he's saying and he's still going
to do a good job and still make me money but
then it but I try not to get into situations
is there a litmus test that you have for
expectations or you can just try to be as
clear as you can you have your own contracts
you have emails and yeah I mean usually I run
a mask in them where they what their goals
are and what their but what their hopes are
I'd say most people come off with pre-reasonable
hopes it's pretty unusual for someone to be pretty
like oh this is for Netflix and just be no
and just knowing that and being totally wrong
that's unusual most people have I find a
certain level of Education of the business
that they know that it's not they know what
it is to a certain degree so I'm helped a
little bit by that but I definitely that's
part of the conversation every single time
if I make it a part of the conversation it's part
of what I when I when we're emailing back and
forth to start that's part of my questionnaire
is like what what are your expectations what
do you hope for or just also usually ask
are there any disturbers you don't like
to get out from them the prejudices that they
might have from the the the from the internet and
but they've heard other Distributors being bashed
on and what they think so I can dispel those myths
to a certain degree as well but yeah those yeah
I have to I have to feel like the client isn't
crazy and I have to feel like they've got hopes
but reasonable expectations at the same time
I like that so you have a questionnaire what like
20 questions not even not even like five questions
oh I see okay a lot of there's more things
come out of that but yes the basic ones are
um what are your expectations for the film what
are the Distributors you don't you're specifically
hoping for are there any Distributors
you particularly don't want to be with
what are you what are your Festival
aspirations those are the main ones
has there ever been a situation where we
absolutely love the film but you've decided not
to take it on no if I love a film I want to take
it on period even if I think it's going to be hard
as long as even if I think it's
not likely to get distribution
as long as the filmmaker understands that it's not
likely to get distribution and I'm going to work
as hard as I can to get a distribution that being
said I don't come across any films that I don't
think can get a certain level of distribution like
for me like I really don't work on Films unless
it's gonna get a deal with an all-rise distributor
that will do it properly and get it on the various
digital platforms I may love it and hope that
it gets better than that and the theatrical
or a Netflix deal something bigger but not
think it's gonna but the odds are against it
but I just need the filmmaker to be clear about
that but if I think a film isn't going to get
it's just I don't know they've
ever seen a film that I loved
that I didn't think would get at
least that level of distribution
I don't think that's happened how many
films have you helped get onto Netflix
I believe it's five to date most of my films
that have gone on the Netflix have gone through
Distributors who then got into Netflix but in
terms of directly I believe it's five how about
this year I know we're early in the oh yeah none
this year none this year okay okay what's the most
recent film you got onto Netflix most recent
trying to think if there's something after
Tinker that got on the Netflix there's a phone
call a kind of Lo-Fi sci-fi film called tinker
I believe that was the last one so the one
where she was a personal assistant to an
insane writer oh okay because that looked good
no Chase Crawford who's in it okay what are the
advantages of a filmmaker getting their movie on
Netflix several things if first of all if you're
beloved by Netflix and they want to bring
you into the fold in terms of making films
one of the few companies that can just say
yes very quickly and finance your your movie
there's a lot of things that come with that
but they're they're definitely they've got a
lot of money to spend on production
the bragging rights are pretty huge
I think that's what film and it's it's a way
some people can see movies very easily everybody
doesn't mind paying the subscription fee no one
has to get out their wallet and pay rent it for
four dollars so you can tell the world about
it and everybody can watch it fairly easily
so I think that's probably the two main
reasons that filmmakers want to be on Netflix
did they have would you say
their their recommendations
are are one of the best in terms of giving you
similar titles so that your movie will be seen
by other movie like if I'm clicking on
one then it's just it's it's so well
sort of the algorithm is so personalized
yeah yeah I've seen I I think that um
I I don't think I've ever so my films have
been very indie and and not Netflix or produced
and so I think they're hard they're hard to find
unless you're told about it at the end of the day
and perhaps like with in the case of Tinker
if you're you love indie film and and sci-fi
I'm not I'm not sure even with all the content
they have now if you which if that film would
show up unless you typed it in and found it
that way so I think it's still hard even to get
visibility on Netflix with an indie unless you're
something of theirs that got a lot more promotion
than something they acquired from a distributor
you think that was probably much different a
few years back before they started producing
their own content oh yeah yeah at least not to
produce movies so they the everything was other
people's content Studio content Disney movies um
um unless yeah unless and and no Netflix
originals at first so yeah definitely a lot easier
any disadvantages being on Netflix
um I depend on your expectations and
what you want I don't I don't think so
they're they're usually paying a license fee for
the right to do it so what you're getting going in
it's a badge of honor these days to say
you're you've got to film on Netflix
I think some clients if they're staring at a a
minimal offer from Netflix versus someone who
wanted to put the film in 10 theaters they have
to choose a path and depending on what they want
out of the film they might choose the theatrical
path because they just want that kind of treatment
[Music] but there have been some deals like
I currently negotiate a deal with a different
streamer where we sold the streamer a pay window
they're going to take it they're paying a license
fee and another distributor is going to come in
and take all the other rights and assume that
contract so they're going to do the theatrical
do the transactional video then it's going to
go to that streamer that bought the film
and then go to other other platforms later
and the same distributor was going to pay a lot
less beforehand when they didn't know about the
the TV deal so they got their cake their cake
and they eat it too so to speak because they got
the I can't say the name yet but the the
cable deal that they're getting and they're
getting someone to take it out on 10 screens
theatrically so that's a win-win in that case
what are the pathways to getting a film on Netflix
these days so there's there's pitching into the
originals division to see if it's say something
they want to take on directly from the filmmaker
or you can be with a distributor who then after
they take it out on transactional VOD will then
try to pitch it to Netflix at the same time they
might pitch HBO Hulu and other streamers to see
if they want to take it usually 90 to 120 days
after the start of the transactional video window
so there's really two paths there's either
directly we can sell it directly or through
a distributor as a window later on and cannot
me as an individual just contact Netflix could
concise just send them a letter and my experience
is not really um just from that's not to prohibit
anybody from trying or who knows if you've
got the right Moxie to get in the door right
but my experience is that filmmakers come to me
have tried have not been able to get someone to
watch it so it's similar to what you were talking
about with the the need for a producer rep in that
some doors are closed yeah some doors are open
maybe they shouldn't be but the ones that are
closed sometimes there's reasons and then you
you do those might actually be the best ones
to try absolutely yeah okay interesting so if
if they know someone or if the distributor that
they've gone with has access that's usually
how it's done yeah or smaller yeah exactly
and do most Distributors promise that or
they entertain it but they don't promise it
both there's some Distributors that that say
there's some Distributors that that will say
yes we're going to pitch it to Netflix and HBO Etc
that same distributor might also want to film but
say hey we want it but we're probably not going
to be able to make a deal with HBO or Netflix if
they're being honest there are some Distributors
that on the lower side of the spectrum that don't
even try because they don't have the relationships
they're smaller Distributors that just can't that
take films out to the transactional vosd space and
the advertising video do you use space but don't
have the relationships to make a deal with Netflix
or Hulu Etc and then there are some Distributors
that kind of pretend they have the relationship
and just say that they can pitch them and really
can't how does an indie filmmaker get in Netflix
original well so there's kind of two ways one is
if you've somehow managed to pitch it to Netflix
and they want to make it with you normally to get
that pitch you've got to be going in with someone
who's made a film with them before they and most
Hollywood based Distributors and just don't
have an open door policy for anybody to just
come in and Pitch anything most of them including
Netflix make films with the production companies
that are owned by stars or just producers
that have been making films for a long time
and so your most likely path is getting involved
with one of them getting somehow getting them to
look at your material and having them want to make
it and take it in to get financing from Netflix
that's one way the other way is to pitch it
to Netflix to the original department and have
them like what you already made and decide hey
we'll we'll make it we'll turn into an original
it seems like they're taking a lot of
or they're making a lot of adaptations
Netflix or at least the ones I've
been watching are yeah yeah they make
all different kinds of content now it's from
reality to documentaries and they're they're
they analyze their the metrics they have
to see what their viewers want dictates
what they make and who they make thumbs with
yeah I've suggested several films because they
have this email thing that you can just put
in would you like to a title we don't have
that you'd like to see and right unfortunately
I haven't seen them up there but I keep trying
and I have no personal investment in it
I just want to see it on there but do you
ever recommend a filmmaker go with just a strict
Netflix deal rather than theatrical [Music] um
um I'm usually following the lead of the
filmmaker on that and trying to see what
their goals are and try to advise them
according to what the what they want
and I can point out depending on what's being
offered what I what I subjectively think is the
best math monetarily as in terms of maximizing the
value was the best bet but if you want a certain
kind of exposure what's the other what's the other
mean because there's all levels of theatrical
from one screen to 10 screens to 100 screens
so it kind of depends on what's being proffered
um and kind of depends on what I think the
filmmaker wants out of it at the end of the day
when you see exposure are they also considering
future projects down the line getting their name
out there maybe is more important than getting
someone to see movie A it's about maybe movie b
or c that's coming yeah I find most filmmakers
have competing goals that aren't necessarily
at odds with each other but many of them will
say well it's most important for me to get
my money back for my investors but it's also
just as important for me to make my get my next
project off the ground so I've really declared
that they've got two important most important
things at the end of the day I'd say and then it
kind of depends because there are some people who
have financed their own thing so they have kind
of they definitely have both things in mind there
are some people I'm dealing with where they have
there's the executive producer that I never meet
and but they're in control of the property
and they're much more concerned about
that going on to the next thing then maybe their
executive producer is so and then I get sometimes
the executive producer is part of the discussion
so they're having to pay attention to that person
and and really the goal is monetization I find
that though usually the best situation for
exposure matches the best um path for monetization
is usually not it's pretty rare to have that
um Netflix offer versus semi-wide theatrical
where you think wow the money's kind of equal
the exposure is kind of equal it's usually
usually someone is is putting up something
that's a lot better than everybody else well
filmmakers make more money from Netflix or
Tubi so it depends on the film Netflix mostly
pays license fees for films straight payments
and here's what will pay you for your film and
we'll get it for this length of time and that's it
two we can do that too now they have paid upfront
monies but to be mostly works with distributors
so like I don't I don't pitch to be because I
just don't find they're really that interested
in taking on true Independent films
directly from filmmakers or from reps
so they're more part of the mix with what the
Distributors doing at the end of the day and
so most films most true Indies are not getting the
Netflix deal but getting on Tubi so they're making
more money by default from Tubi on their films if
they were to get it if if they if Netflix did buy
the film and then eventually it got on Tubi it
could be that it could be that the Netflix deal
was so good that they'll never make as much money
on Tubi as they did for that deal or it could be a
small license fee and then it takes off on Tubi
because it's the right kind of content for Tubi
so yeah it just kind of depends it's not really
a very straightforward answer to that really
working filmmakers go to make the most money on
their films so I would say the in general [Music]
most people are going to make the most money
through all rights Distributors to handle all
these various platforms and maximize all the
platforms as best they can for the filmmaker
ideally you get a big fat
license fee from a streamer
ideally you get a lot or or ideally you get
a large minimum guarantee a payment up front
from your distributor to handle the rights
which they'll recoup from revenues later
but that doesn't happen for most movies so and
most movies don't get the direct-to-streaming deal
so most movies get the All rights distribution
digital and sales deals that are out there
and for me unless you want to put on the hat
of self-distribution for six months to a year
and you have the right kind
of film for self-distribution
the path of going that way with an all
rights distributor is the best way to go
on the other hand if you've made a
documentary about dogs and you have
great contacts with organizations that are
devoted to dogs saving dogs rescue organizations
lovers of dogs on in social media groups and
you've cultivated over that time or you're willing
to go and cultivate that and there are there are
people out there that can help you do that there's
a couple of great kind of self-distribution gurus
out there that are great at teaching you how to
maximize the that the value
out of that kind of film
and there have been a couple filmmakers I said
well you've got the kind of film you should
probably do that with rather than going through
me and trying to get traditional distribution
um but for the most part if you've made a comedy
drama Thriller horror or family film a narrative
film or a documentary that doesn't have a knee
like that kind of Niche that you and and you
don't have a self-distribution hat that you want
to put on self-devision is not the thing to do
like it's a overwhelming undertaking and it's and
it's got its own risk is not foolproof you can
go out there and do all those things this those
self-distribution things and it not work as well
but as long as you're happy with that and that's
the thing you want to do that that could be the
option for some some filmmakers but overwhelmingly
most people are going to maximize the value of
their film by going into an all-rise distributor
that handles all the various rights what if you
have a Christmas film or a women in Peril slash
women in power whatever they're called now
so so there's lots of there's lots of options
for both of those genres kind of depends on
the quality of the film and how it comes out but
the both of those are in demand internationally
both of those you have to sell it
at the right time of year though
because you need a long lead time like most
Christmas films are released in November
to be released in November you have to
made your deal with someone by August or so
so the best time to sell I mean truly the best
time to sell a Christmas film is probably May
because then you're giving your
distributor a lot of time to
really get everything going and geared
up properly for that release in November
but you see Christmas films on Netflix
and on all the different streamers and
theatrical and it's definitely if you
pull it off it's it's it's definitely
I think there's lower like there's a margin
for error there there isn't with other films
same with well I think women in Peril Thrillers
there's also a margin of error there like you
can the film doesn't have to be quite as good in
order to make money because it's a such desired
genre and that's overseas as well as domestic
yeah oh wow for both of those interesting what
is the self-distribution Hat just in a nutshell
what what is that so [Music] there are different
methodologies that different people teach on on
how to self-distribute a movie and that usually
involves trying to identify groups out there that
would have natural inclination to dig your film
and then whether it's going whether it's going
after those people on social media directly and
trying to Market directly to them or it's creating
Partnerships with organizations that have the
same cause and doing free screenings with those
people in order to create word of mouth and then
sell to their have them in exchange for doing
a free screening they Market to their the the
larger group of people in their organization
that's the way I've seen a couple of people what
a couple of self-distribution gurus teaching
these days in terms of techniques to try to
but it takes a lot of time and effort and it's a
different mindset that a lot of film most of my
filmmakers like okay I'm done with my job I want
to distribute or distribute the movie and don't
have the and don't want to spend six months to
they want to they want that movie to get out and
make money and they want to get under they want
to be creative and make the next project and they
don't have that salesmanship marketing and you
really got to get after it I mean in order to make
it work it's not as easy as like finding a group
on dog lovers on social media and then just send
them a message you got to really engage with them
and get them and connect with them and over time
make yourself well known to them and and
become a part of that culture almost in order
to do that kind of self-distribution there
are a couple anomalies of filmmakers that
managed to get some money in order to help do
their own self-distribution of a non-documentary
film where it was a a comedy or a thriller but
usually it took it when they did it they managed
to pre-sell they they had someone that pre-sold
rights to a foreign territory and they took that
money or they got money from some a Sundance
or some company entity that was just wanting
to support them and they poured that money
into a theatrical release and either they
booked the theater themselves and figured out
how to do that or they hired a Booker and then
then perhaps they really most of them do end up
doing a deal with a distributor though at that
point they handle all the various digital rights
rather than going through an aggregator so most
most successful self-distribution of
non-documentaries that I've seen have
been pretty well funded to do a theatrical and
that helped the overall picture of the film
how many filmmakers do who make a living making
movies so I've had several clients who have gone
on to great careers in making films I sold Chaka
King's first film newlyweeds who went on to do
Judas in the Messiah one of Mike Flanagan's
early films Absentia who now made this the the
The Shining SQL and lots of other great
horror films and and series for Netflix
um I I co-produced and helped sell
several films with Ron Bergman who's
a producer he's now partnered with Ryan
Johnson and they did Star Wars 8 and
Looper and several other knives
out and several other great films
so I have a handful of clients that have
gone on to to have great Hollywood careers
I have a few clients as well that
still make movies are still trying
to make that one that graduates to the
studio level but still making indie films
some some still very Indie some kind of in
the Quasi Hollywood Indie world of catching
talent and having sales agents pre-sell their
move movies there's lots of those movies that
kind of out there that don't bubble up but
still kind of make money in strange ways
and and then there's a lot of people that are one
and done just because it was so such a big effort
to get that first one out there and they just
never could get quite back to making number two
that's partly because it's just hard
to make a film that makes money and
and I think it's it's easier when you're
young I like to bootstrap it and do it for
nothing and get all call in all your favors
but it's hard to call in the favors twice
so yeah it's definitely a mix sure
and if you have debt from the movie
yeah that's difficult yeah yeah so and most people
I know I think most films I rep were mostly equity
most of them tend to be have found an equity
investor to make the film as opposed to renting
their credit cards so it's not debt per se and
that they have to pay it back they just have
disgruntled investors maybe but or not overly
happy but but yeah I think it's yeah it's just
it's just not it's not easy to make a movie
and it's um I'd say me I don't know what the
percentages are but I'd say probably 70 percent 80
percent don't go on to make a second film at least
well that's that's high that's unfortunate but
yeah well there's just a lot of stuff that
I mean we've got a lot of movies out there
and it's not that like they don't go on to
do great things other ways right like it's
see I've definitely had clients like like wow
I made this film but I'm never doing it again
like they that's the way they feel after after
making for one like it's just it was a lot to
to get that one off the ground whatever that
felt like to them so yeah it's not always a
sad story it's sometimes just what they choose
they just choose A New Path right they got it
out of their system yeah yeah exactly what's the
budget range of the movies you typically work with
yeah the range is micro to like almost
nothing to several million three four million
I'm maybe a couple times I've had seven million
dollar films but pretty rare how does a half
million dollar movie make its money back so there
are lots of potential ways to make it back but
for a half million dollar movie you most
likely need to get it into a major Festival
and have someone pay you
that and more back up front
because if you most half million dollar films
don't make their money back so that's you know
it's just half a million dollars it implies no
cast really right that I mean when I say no Castle
I mean there are people in the movie but there's
no names in the movie per se that help sell it
and that's you're going up against a lot of
independent films out there that have names
that were made at two million dollars and even
those movies don't get sometimes don't get a half
million dollars for their U.S sale so you're
really up against it it's really it's tough
but I have had plenty of half million dollar
movies that made a hundred thousand in the
transactional VOD world the distributor managed
to sell to cable entity for a couple hundred
thousand and then it made more money on AVOD
to get to that half million dollar number
I'm sorry AVOD sorry advertising video
on demand and that's where the ads play
that's where the ads oh and you can't expect
okay great sorry are there certain films that
are domestically made but they are hits overseas
but they're not here it's pretty rare these days
the one of the reasons I decided to get into
domestic sales as a producer rep as opposed to
International sales was I saw it going down 15
years ago um there was a day when International
sales was Major and talk about we're talking about
true Indies here okay not there's still a market
overseas for films with names in quasi-independent
films made by Hollywood production companies
we talk about true indie films there's barely a
market now overseas and that's partly because at
one point we we used to be able to sell almost
anything overseas 25 years ago the this is there
were cable channels around the world and video
stores around the world that needed content and
U.S producers were the only ones that could make
them at a price and we were the only ones really
doing it in mass and so we were flooding the
world with our content so fast forward past
the writer strike creates the reality television
and the cross cost of production all comes down
and countries around the world start making their
own content for their own communities there's
just not there's just no Demand anymore at all for
True Independent films there's still a pretty good
I almost say good but there's still a business
for films into three million dollars in up range
that are made in not with that with the studio but
independently in Hollywood with a name attached to
it where they can make sales around the world
that come up to 50 to 70 percent of a budget
but that doesn't exist for True Independence
even if they get someone and they pay them
a day rate maybe they weren't they're not an
a-lister but they're recognizable yeah these
days you it's like to me for for sales
purposes it's really A-list or nothing
I think when you're when you're if
you're gonna if you're casting for
name value and it's that level you should
also be making you should possibly really
be getting them because they're really great for
the role much more important than what their name
value is and you're hoping that the combination
of them being great for the role and a little
bit of name value catapults it into another
sphere then the you everything else out there
but yeah I see a lot of films that cast B level
talent I should say not level but value Talent
for that purpose and it just
doesn't didn't make a difference
right I'm just thinking of overseas as well
so it sounds like maybe 15 16 20 years ago
yeah we could do that easily back then there
was a it was a day when you could just tell
an international distributor oh I've got so
and so in it and and they just believed you
right and that they didn't even know that the
person had value or not and that's how that's how
Westworld it was at one point or Wild but
they're all much more sophisticated now
they all know exactly what they need and what
their audiences want and who's worth what and so
it's it's really kind of again there's again going
back to those three million dollar level films
where there are some actors that have kind of
popped up in value because they were in big Studio
films and so there's a certain recognizability
there's certain name value that's still there but
they're not getting they're not leading roles
in in big Studio movies they still are trying
out for them maybe they're trying to be the next
Marvel guy or whatever but they're not getting it
but they still have some value so for a few years
they'll be castable in that kind of budget range
and usually in Thrillers or horror films or
elevated horror something very commercial
action as well but but it's but that list is
pretty it's a pretty small list and it changes
and it's subjective too I find that like just
because one sales company has an affinity
for one level one actor with a little
bit of name value they might have
that Affinity because they had a film last
year that they sold with him that did well
but the sales agent over here doesn't have that
experience and doesn't didn't hasn't made a film
with that guy so they don't have this put the
same value on him that that other company does
so it's not like a a where like you can't rely
on IMDb scores for Value they really sometimes
they correlate but most of the time they don't
because people pop up and down on that list
pretty wildly now this faith-based films is the
only place to sell them is to certain Networks
yeah I'm not that conversant and faith-based
stuff I've never sold a faith-based film
from what I understand there's a mega church
that kind of there's one or two of them that
have done quite a good job in the past of of
of creating these faith-based films for their
their audiences and and Screen those
films for the churches as a way to
create a Groundswell for selling
off the ancillary rights later
and and and I think that there's their faith-based
production companies that have kind of figured
out the formula and the name value that they
need and can kind of and know how to do that
but if someone came to me with a face faith-based
film I'd say hey if it if it also works for
a secular audience I know where to go with it
but if it's purely faith-based and very or very
overtly faith-based there's better there's there's
routes that I don't really know that much about
how does film negotiation work so usually
if a distributor wants a film they'll reach
out with terms either everybody does
a little bit differently some people
will poke at me and say well what do you want
some will just send me an email saying okay here's
the here's what we would do for the film here's
the distribution fee and then either they have a
a term sheet or they just type it into an email
um usually the next step is I present that
to my filmmaker explain the company to them
and what what they're about introduce them to
them so they can hear from the horse's mouth
so the distributor can tell them exactly what
they were going to do with the film and how
much they like the film Etc and then we repeat
that process with any other offers coming in
then I usually try to help the client make a
decision in terms of which way they want to go
and then depending on which way they want to go
there are some Distributors that have come at us
exactly where they want to be and I just know
from experience there's no negotiation they've
come at me with the lowest distribution fee they
ever offer the lowest cap on expenses they'll do
the less term they'll do and and then there
are some companies I know that they've come
at me a little higher than what they'll do and
I know what the wiggle room is ahead of time
and so depending on who the client is chosen
I'll tell them okay well here's where I think
we can move the contract on this if they
give me the green light then I usually call
the distributor and say hey here's they like
you best but only if you can make these terms
and then if they agree then we're good and we go
to a long form and then there's a long form to
negotiate as well but usually I've seen most
of the long forms for all the companies that
I've dealt with and some of them I've redlined
it before and already got a pound of Flash and I
know exactly what they're gonna what they're gonna
agree to or not so there really is no need to get
into that in order to make the deal we can just
make a deal based on the deal memo or the email
and then and then worry about the long form
after the fact and if they don't come to if
they don't agree to whatever I'm proffering in
terms of a counter I go back to the client say
well they wouldn't go down do you want to you
want to try them again or you want to respond
to their counter to our counter or do you want to
go given that do you want to try the other person
because maybe they're more amenable and maybe you
like them more now that you've heard that they
won't do what you want to do and so then I'll go
and but usually only negotiate with one at a time
it's just you don't negotiate with two entities
at the same time because if they both accept you
if you gave them if you counted both of them they
both said yes then you've you've committed fraud
so you don't want to do that so you only deal
with one at a time until there's an acceptance
of an offer then you then you have a deal and
sorry a term sheet is what a term sheet usually
um is just a either piece of paper or a PDF that
has the basic terms of an agreement not all the
language of the agreement so it'll spell out
usually a term sheet will have the length of
the contract the rights the maybe not all
the like it'll say video on demand rights
DVD and Blu-ray rights advertising video and
demand rights it's what rights they're taking
but it won't have a description of each right
which will be in the long form agreement
it'll have the term it'll have the if there's
a minimum guarantee that they're going to
pay against the rights against against the
revenues then that'll be in the term sheet
and then beyond the major things the
depending on the distributor they might have
how the just a quick couple lines on how
they do accounting a quick couple lines
on expenses and whether they cap them or
not and so there might be a couple things
to flesh out in the term sheet depending on
how specific or or not specific term sheet is
before we go to long form to make sure okay we
don't want to agree to this because there's a
little ambiguity in the term sheet in terms of
like accounting rights so let's be sure that what
we mean here is quarterly for two years not just
or quarterly for the whole time or what you want
to be as specific as possible before you say yes
but some of that I already know because I've seen
their long forms before so we can we can work off
just the basic terms in order to make it a deal
so it's almost like a cliff notes yeah for the
okay and then the long form is is how many pages
usually depends on the distributor some it can
be five or six pages some it can be 26 30 pages
some of them have agreements where they have
kind of the basic terms in the first three or
four pages and then what's called a standard terms
and conditions document that's kind of stapled to
it that kind of gets into the nitty-gritty of
everything defining all the terms defining all
the rights and all those things so it depends
it depends on the company to a certain degree
how lengthy it is and what what is the usual the
standard length of term or does it vary depending
it does vary the the range is 3 to 15. oh Years
Years you do you do see 20 even from bigger deals
but they're plunking down a lot of money
they're really making it their film
I would say most of my deals are in the seven
year range usually we're negotiating down from
15 to seven but then there are a couple companies
they're more aggressive and do like three years
but you find that all companies have executive
there that's like well we never do below three
years or we never do below seven it had their own
standard that they just won't they just won't go
below because and I find that most companies
that want longer terms the reason they want
longer terms or a couple one is they have these
big libraries and they want if new ways to release
films come out on the market they want to have
this huge library of films that they can monetize
that new way so for instance advertising video
and demand or AVOD is relatively new platform
so all these companies that had all these movies
suddenly had a whole other way to monetizing these
films and if they had only had three years
there'd be four or five years of films that
they didn't have to put through this these
platforms another reason is it looks better
on your books to have long terms so if someone's
evaluating of a bank is evaluating your company
if you're trying to sell it to someone
and you have 20 films for three years
they think well geez in three years this is
nothing like so and if and anyone I could be
able to monetize it with a new platform that comes
around like like if AVOD or something like it
so there are assets on the books of these
Bank of these companies so Banks just value
them more if they have longer terms on their
contracts interesting and is it reasonable to
expect the longer the terms of the contract
the more or the possibility of an advance
no not really well I should say maybe the the
companies are doing three years are not doing
advances yeah so I guess I guess yes is actually
the answer to that question so the companies are
doing 7 10 15 years are more likely to do advances
[Music] and I think that's I think that's because
they just don't have to be as aggressive as the
three-year they're usually offering a little bit
more than the companies that are doing three years
they haven't longer they've been around longer
they might be doing theatrical on some of
their movies they just have bigger pipeline
yeah they're a little bit more they're not
having to be as aggressive to get films than
the companies that are doing the three-year terms
yeah I think the movies that I've watched on Tubi
these were all films that have been out for
20 plus years so yeah that makes sense yeah
that would be the case for wanting them to
on their I don't know they want them on their
books but establish names from filmmakers
that have been around yeah exactly why
does slam dance co-founder and filmmaker
Dan mervish call you a shrewd negotiator
um because I paid him okay all right that's
good I don't know I Dan's a great friend I I
met him early on in the in the days of slam dance
because I think I attended the second slam dance
and been going ever since and I've had every
year I have two to four movies at slam dance
and then at some point I struck up a friendship
with Dan's been so long I don't remember when
and then I remember even when he when
he was going around with his second film
I read it gave him some comments on it I don't
think anything to do with that one and then later
on I've sold a couple I've sold now two films for
him and kind of consulted him on another one and
and Dan's a very Dan is a little much more
knowledgeable than your average Indie filmmaker
so he's definitely a big part of the process
when I'm helping when I when I have helped
him sell a film and and so there's a
shorthand there too and so I think he
I think more than anybody he knows a little
bit more than my average client what I know
and how helpful I can be and so like like
I said there are some people like Dan Dan
could probably take the time and do what
I do and get everybody to watch the film
it might it might take longer because he he's not
doing it year round like I am and I think that's
why any and because I stare at it I know all
these things he knows by experience what I know
and and yeah then it comes in negotiation
that's fun because it's we we go back and forth in
terms of like how we're going to try to influence
the buyer that he likes to do do the best by it
so how do you negotiate the best deal for a movie
well to a certain degree I I think that
most films I'm working on are going to this
certain level of distributor and there's only a
certain range that we're going to be negotiating
and I already know going in what the
best position that these negotiations
will do for really any film if it hits
that range so there's some films where
um I just know exactly where they'll go
I know where they won't go and it's it's
more about communicating the filmmaker like
here your here are your options here's how
we can kind of push a little bit or pull a
little bit it does get more interesting when
it's a it's a it gets above that level and we're
getting theatrical offered and and I I find that
it's best to go to Distributors with the position
of hey they really want to be with you but here's
what you got to do I'm not a fan of like say well
so and so wants it are you going to beat them
I'm not a fan of um telling people what we
want upfront usually if a Disturbia comes to
me and says well what do you want I'm saying
I usually say we want the best possible deal
because I don't want to undersell it I want
them to come to me with the best possible thing
there's a little bit of that I guess I've
been doing it so much and so I I don't
find it that complicated a lot of it's
intuitive and a lot of it's just knowing
knowing who I'm dealing with pretty well and
and knowing where they'll go where they won't
so you're not trying any well if you don't let us
know in five days I have X Y and Z over here that
they want it and you'd be crazy to lose after
this just doesn't work yeah it just doesn't
and especially since I'm I mean maybe if I was
just a one-off person and they didn't know me
and had no history of dealing with me
but almost everybody I'm selling films
to I've sold two films for a couple decades
so it's there's it's there's it's a lot more
it's a lot more straightforward and like like
this is really the I also know since I know
where they'll potentially go I know where they
won't go I know not to go to them with something
crazy that they won't do and I have in situations
where filmmaker is like well push him anyway like
hey they won't pay in advance but ask for one
anyway and I'll do it I don't care but I'm always
right I mean they're not good to they're not
going to do what I know they're not going to do
I don't think I've ever been surprised that way
another rule of thumb there is that if someone's
if someone's made an advance offer an mg offer
then they're probably movable on it a little bit
if if but not not a hundred percent greater than
what they've offered so they've offered you twenty
thousand they're probably not going to forty they
might go to 25 or 30. that that's a generalization
if they offered nothing they're probably not
offering anything they're probably not moving
even to one thousand dollars because that's
just not the way they see it this transaction
so it's just knowing those things I think that
helps the negotiation so you you pretty much know
the rules of the game the players in the game
and where those films are going to plug in and
there's probably not a lot of leeway like you
said if someone's not going to give a minimum
guarantee they're probably not going to do a
thousand or Twenty Thousand for one right exactly
that's not to say I am surprised by who
wants what though and it's not like I like
I'm I'm selling the film right now to HBO I
didn't know HBO was going to want the movie
or pay a good license fee for it I had no idea
and my my next best offer was not even close
to what they offered so it's not that I
know what's going to happen I just know
once they make the offer I know I know
where they'll go and where they won't go
how often are these negotiations in person and how
often are they via email Skype yeah they're all
a combination of zoom and and email and phone
even pre-covered overwhelmingly unless you're
selling film at Sundance they were selling the
film The Sundance or South by Southwest and
it's in person then you're going to a condo
and you're meeting meeting people in person
if there have been times though I guess
there are occasions though where I have
had filmmakers go to meet distributors in
Los Angeles as part of the process pre-covid
but I don't need to be there because I'm just
putting them together to meet in order to talk
creative and what they do for the film and then
the negotiation will happen by phone or or by
email afterwards because so much of it needs to
be in writing yeah there's just no reason to get
together like there's no reason to get in a car
and drive 30 minutes to just do what you can do
pretty more efficiently by by phone
or email can you explain a deal memo
Dillman was a term sheet at the end of the
day so Dil memo is the basic terms of a deal
the term the length of the the contract the
minimum guarantee if they're going to pay
something up front for the movie The number of
years the rights they're going to take and then
some of the other factors that they every demo is
a little bit or term sheets a little bit different
in terms of what they'll they'll put out there
in terms of what they are it's kind of a it's
like you said earlier Cliff Notes version of
the contract okay sorry I didn't realize the
deal member was the same thing it's termites
okay maybe you said that okay without naming
names what's the worst distribution deal you've
seen a distributor offer one of your films laughs
um that's a great question
um well certainly not one that I
ever would allow someone to take
it usually when I see a bad one it
has to do with how revenues are shared
and they're just the Distributors just taking
too much there are some deals where there's some
Distributors out there that use other Distributors
to get their films out into the marketplace
um and so they're taking a percentage after the
distributor who's doing the work is taking a
percentage after iTunes has taken a percentage
right so when from iTunes to distributor to
distributor to you and some distributors small
these are smaller companies don't disclose it
and say Hey this is our distribution fee but just
so we're also going through this other company
there are companies though that do legitimately
and say okay this is our distribution fee and
it's inclusive of the Distribution Company that
is actually doing the work they're getting it out
there or they'll say it is on top of and yes it's
a big fee but but that's what we that's the way we
do it it's just a little bit more legitimate
than hiding it right so the worst deal is is
the combination of the fact that it's fee on top
of a fee and they're not revealing they're just
going to give you a royalty statement that says
what came in and what they took from it without
explaining that another level of Revenue went from
one person to another person that came to them
that makes sense why would a filmmaker even I mean
why would a company even think that a filmmaker
would entertain it's like an extra middle man
it's not just a middle man it sounds like a
well again some people don't reveal it and they
don't know that's the familiar doesn't know to
ask the question ah right and okay there I do know
one company that will reveal it if you ask them
but they don't reveal it if they don't if you
don't ask them which and it's just really strange
because I like without naming names I like a lot
of things about these people they're really they
do other things kind of right but that one aspect
of it I like why why like and I guess it's because
probably because they're not winning movies
because they have to re that when they do reveal
that some people filmers are like well I can't
give you a percentage on top of another percentage
um and I know another company though that what
they figured out to do is to make the company that
they go through have their fee inclusive of their
fee so the fee that they're proffering it might be
more like 30 35 because they're having to account
for giving 15 to someone else but at least it's
it's more competitive than charging 25 on top of
20. right so you do get different kinds out there
but overwhelmingly most of my films all almost
all of my films almost 100 go through companies
that there's just one fee being paid taken out
there's there's one distributor I go through
who takes a fee but has it inclusive of
this company he's going through and he's a
he's an honorable ex-studio guy who was very
straightforward about what he does and essentially
the way the the conundrum that Distributors that
people have when they've become a dis they want
to become a distributor is how do I get to Market
right because anybody I could go tomorrow and say
hey I'm a distributor you give me the movie and I
go put it on iTunes through a lab I just pay the
encoding fee really easy what's harder is to sell
at the cablevod and to establish a distribution
relationship with the streamers and established
relationship with Tubi and the other advertising
video on demand companies that's harder to
do and so what some people decide is hey I
want to distribute movies but I don't have those
relationships I'll create a partnership with a
bigger company I'll go to the cost of acquiring
and marketing the movies and we'll just have a
relationship with this company where they are the
ones who put it on the platforms and do the sales
and that's fine if you're above board about it
and your fee isn't too and you're able to do a fee
structure that Inc that doesn't take too much out
of the dollar but if it's if you don't reveal it
quasi-criminal to me it's not criminal
but it's very unethical and um
and then and then just the fee structure is just
crazy like if you do a fee on top of fee it's
just like how do you how do you make any money
it's very hard so if a filmmaker was doing the
DIY wearing the distribution hat themselves and
and they've been approached or they approached
someone and they don't realize this is not that
there's not just one Phoebe how are they going to
uncover that what kind of clues or paper trail
or how are they going to do a search to see so
some platforms like Amazon and others have in
the details of the film they'll have like the
copyright date and a little bit of information
and some of them have the distributor name
and so if the distributor isn't your
distributor most likely they put it
through somebody else oh wow right but that
would be too late at that point oh yeah
there's a there's a there are definitely
a lot of there are a lot of companies that
just don't do it properly one way or another
um and I just don't send them my movies it's
showing me easily easily handled that way sure
it's real fun it's sort of this omitting very
important information yeah interesting so that
it would be very difficult until you get to
a point where you can't even get out of the
contract it sounds like yeah I mean like I said
like distribution contracts are hard to get out of
they're not they're not built to be
easy to get out of and especially if
you're working with someone who didn't tell you
everything up front about how they do business
most likely they don't really
care if you want to get out either
right that's the kind of person they
are so that's why it's very important
if if you are diying it if you are going to
distributors or producer reps or anybody you
should be checking IMDb and calling those
filmmakers and and trying to get enough of
them to tell you what their experiences were so
that you can make a a little bit of an educated
decision on on where to go sure and even in doing
that you can still run into problems and 100 so
people know each other they could be friends they
could have alliances yeah it's real tricky but
yeah that's interesting I I did not know that
so that's for for filmmakers that because in
that that there's a bigger chunk being taken out
because there's this extra person that's right.